this is a production of cornell
university
all right welcome back everyone uh to
episode nine this year the cornell turf
show we're we're five weeks into our
spring series
uh our guest today hopefully will be
john daniels
usga agronomist for our northeast region
here
hoping to have john on later uh talking
about some of the usga tools they're
coming out with data that that will help
superintendents
and of course if if he joins us i know
he's traveling around the northeast uh
getting some of his thoughts on what
he's seen uh out in the field here this
year but uh as always frank let's let's
start out with you and uh what we're
looking at weather-wise here uh what
we've seen and what uh let's go up here
let's go up here to the videotape
all right you got me
yeah looks great
good okay so uh welcome to the show
thanks again to the long island
superintendents and the met
superintendents for
providing the funding and for richard
brown for just the cutest picture of a
future water at east lake uh golf club
down in atlanta i love a good uh smiley
face
i think those are legos maybe heading
for my feet
so
i know for many years of doing that um
it's always good to be sure when you got
the little one on the floor i think if
you look close at the tweet he's got his
shoes off too so you're bound to get
them under there we got to start him
young to get him interested in this
so uh carl uh before i pass it to you uh
you know you walked us through a
master's preview a couple of weeks ago
and there was a lot of tweets about the
differences between you know what
happens at augusta national and there's
a there was a couple of really funny
ones where they showed these pictures
and then you know like showed a car
broken down somewhere or mower broken
down uh somewhere obviously this is
something that gets the conversation
going in golf uh every spring because
it's in the same place it's familiar and
as you and i know there's an enormous
amount of resources invested in that so
why don't i pass it to you here and take
us through the tip of the day
yeah frank so we're doing these tip of
the days every week uh in conjunction
with our project with uh our friends at
p2i
looking at bmps and we actually talked
about this i believe it was last week
but long grass and looking at the carbon
emissions you can save
from transitioning from uh routinely cut
rough to these long grass naturalized
areas
and today what we want to highlight is
is not so much uh what we can gain out
of those but how you you figure out
where do i put these areas
um and the common issue that we run into
is golfers golfers are using the
landscape they don't like long grass
so how do we balance
the ability to potentially reduce our
inputs
with hey golfers have to use this
landscape and if there's long grass that
inhibits them from using the golf course
slows down play and makes golfers angry
so the way we can do that is through
data
and we're going to show you some data
here
um if you go to the next slide frank
this is
data we've used with the usga's deakin
system this is part of their deacon tool
we have john on today to talk
more about this but essentially what we
did is we handed out gps loggers these
were provided to us by the usga to each
of our golfers we did this for almost
200 golfers at our golf course
you can see if you're watching the video
here these are the golfer tracks across
the entire golf course you can see where
the golfers go these gps trackers
uh ping every five seconds
we could figure out okay one of the
many ways you can use this data is
where do golfers uh go and where do they
not go and you can see some highlighted
areas here
uh very obviously there's a low density
of golfers maybe two percent of golfers
go in some of these areas these are
great long grass candidates and areas to
transition so we actually have a case
study here
um about this project how much acreage
we were able to identify uh more than
eight acres under this golf course
that can be a transition because they
are low density areas for golfers um so
this is a really data driven way to kind
of convince your golfers hey you know
only two percent of our golfers hit it
in here that's a low amount enough
a low enough amount of golfers that we
can
rationalize making that long grass so
we'll talk more with john about this but
one of the many ways you can use data is
to outline some of these long grass
areas especially the visualization of
the data right carl this is data that we
collected and we'll talk more about this
with john and he's with us right yep yep
all right good john welcome aboard hope
you haven't seen too much of this uh uh
you know this is uh the number three
green at rtj um back tucked in a corner
not not the greatest spot if gil gets
his hands on it it's gonna look uh gill
hands gets his hands on it's gonna look
very different uh in the future but you
can see some of the damaged pola but
more importantly when you look close
carl's uh advertisement for bent grass
once again uh comes out here and you
know again ben grass getting a bad rap
for not doing well early um here's some
bent grass looking like if i had a whole
putting green of it i might be able to
do something with it so i do think uh as
we get the season going and we talk
about the weather a little bit we get a
better sense of how recovery is going
jed newsom in western mass has been very
active uh sending pictures about this um
poe went full undertaker and it rose
from the dead without me doing a darn
thing very interesting right i think uh
he has been using covers i think you can
see in the background the covers are
there so short of the covers i don't
know if he's doing anything but
certainly uh this is good to keep track
of how things are going it's you know
this is one of the total upsides of of
these social media
uh platforms that allow us to understand
how things are happening around us that
you know actually matter
so let's get through some of the weather
as we get going it was a warmer than
normal week but not by much
when you look out into western pa and
out in west virginia to high elevations
certainly below normal
as you get closer to the coast uh as
much as eight degrees above more normal
all the way out on a cape in the east
end of long island
uh but for sure in the zero to four
degrees above normal
now the roller coaster that our
weather person rt guy tano talked about
with us this morning was that it looks
like we're going to be hitting pause
again uh looks like we're expected to be
uh below normal for the next uh six to
ten day outlook
uh so that's going to have very profound
impact on the already uh important
growing degree day development so on the
left
you're seeing that um a lot of the areas
are right around normal it's looking
like a a pretty normal spring certainly
within you know three to seven days
along the coast
and maybe behind three to seven days as
you get north and and west now degree
days are going to start accumulate a
little a little bit more especially when
you get into central jersey up the
hudson valley into the connecticut river
valley up the pioneer valley a little
bit you'll start to see 15 to as many as
30 growing degree days base 50 grown
degree days
get accumulated in the next five or six
days so why are we paying attention to
growing degree days well you may still
be considering seed head suppression
seed head suppression is probably only
marginal in the highest elevations
mighty or early uh ideal or early in the
highest elevations marginal as you get
uh south of uh you know basically
uh the pennsylvania new york border once
you get uh south of that you're you're
almost out of the ideal range and uh
embark and proxy in the next several
days uh if you're doing seed head
suppression with these tools the models
seem to indicate it's good timing now
on the order of degree days temperatures
and uh forsythia
as a uh targeting tool
as a phenological indicator particularly
for the uh annual bluegrass weevil
we chatted with rich buckley this
morning and he reported on the ground
that he's starting to see some green uh
in the jersey air in in north jersey uh
green and gold starting to happen on
these uh
uh forsythias as indicators of peak
emergence of annual bluegrass and so uh
albrecht the professor at rutgers a guy
who studies uh annual bluegrass weevil
down there and you know has helped
people like ben mcgraw and olga who we
had on last week study this and and get
smarter about it is saying that it's
about time uh for peak germination in
new jersey
uh so i think when you start to think
about um the metropolitan new york area
long island i think you should check
your various models and tools that you
use for this uh and begin to consider
uh scouting and looking for peak
emergence right we talked about this at
length last week that really efficient
use of the insecticide is the time
adulticide application if you don't have
significant pyrethroid uh resistance is
to time it with peak emergence one
application peak emergence get that
number down now as olga said it doesn't
mean that you don't use a larvicide
because we've got a lot of good
larvicides that you can time and again
last week we talked about the potential
for pyrethroid resistance to impact the
performance of your larvacide
in the early phases of that application
so make sure if you go back and listen
to that this is obvious some something
you want to be paying attention to
soils warmed quick
right just like the air heat wave the
the two in soil temperatures track that
air temperature pretty good you see that
we're well into the 50s so fairy ring
applications uh take all patch drenches
uh fungicide drenches that we use early
spring for some of our root issues might
be a little early for summer patch
summer patch maybe 65 degrees but you
want to start monitoring these soil
temperatures and as my colleague carl
showed last week a good old meat
thermometer will do just as well if you
don't want to buy a fancy uh tool so
let's talk about rainfall for a second
and you can see that sua through
northern jersey all the way up to the
hudson valley to the adirondacks a
little bit west to maybe deposit new
york just just uh east of binghamton
um this swath of of three to four inches
of rainfall uh that went up this is the
kind of thing uh where you then look at
the stark difference where it didn't
rain in buffalo and rochester last week
and it doesn't look like it's going to
be raining in buffalo and rochester uh
this coming week so again you look south
you see drier conditions total precip uh
and you look in that one vein and you're
soaked so one of the things that's
starting to happen that art reminded us
of this morning is that now that the
sun's starting to move further in the
sky we're getting the contribution from
evapotranspiration right so you probably
should be noticing some of your surfaces
beginning to dry a little bit right and
the three-day forecast is indicating
that it's right going to be dry in many
areas and as you look further north and
into northern maine where it's been
fairly dry a lot lately
they're going to get a little bit of
rainfall up there as we say for the five
people who live up there uh but pretty
dry for the next several days the three
day moving forward and some of that is
e.t is catching up right we're at the
quarter starting to approach half an
inch for the week right so we're
starting to lose you know maybe a tenth
of an inch a day getting creeping in on
a tenth of an inch a day
and the outlook is indicating somewhat
normal precip particularly uh
in the center area maybe above as you go
north and a little bit below normal as
you go south so maybe on the dry side
but maybe some rain coming in before
saturday or saturday looks like it's
going to be the turning day all right
we're going to get to our guest and i'm
going to set you up a little bit here
john giving my little spiel about data
driven i've really liked how the usga
has moved uh in this direction as other
platforms have as well but the usga with
the deacon system making a big splash
here right and i think about how you
know
once we figured out how to use numbers
in baseball the impact it's had on the
game
i mean they're starting to change things
dramatically because of what happened as
a result of using more data right you
look at a guy who completely changed his
body
based on data so this is more uh
pertinent to golf in particular
are your golfers using data on your golf
course for how they play
right you know my my favorite tweeter
lou stagner you know basically the guy
who reminds us how much everybody
actually sucks at golf the best use lou
has managing your expectations but those
expectations many times are going to be
refined more with data
and so you're going to see more of that
and obviously all the tools that we use
to collect the data that drive the
things that we manage
you know are really important two of
them in particular right developed in
partnership with the usga
and then we've looked at some large
scale data collection tools like we've
done some soil mapping at the robert
trent jones golf course over the years
with the uh rx 360 method that helena
uses we did some em uh mapping of the
fairways and rough areas on the golf
course and then it allows us to
interpret it that data in different ways
right we take the soil samples uh from
the map soils and then you interpret
them using the sufficiency level and
you're going to treat 70 of the fairway
if you interpret that same data using
mlsn you're not going to treat any of
that fairway now all of this is
predicated on how good your turf looks
right so you've got to do a little bit
of ground truing even when you you know
especially when you look at data at this
scale
right so carl did a great job couple
years ago during covid showing pictures
like this put the drone up uh visualized
how the traffic is off the fairway you
know you get out here uh into these
rough areas you see the focused traffic
in these areas you see how they
basically stayed off the fairway and of
course last week when we were in
saratoga joe lucas was telling us he
makes him drive on the fairway right so
so here's use of data but this is visual
date so john uh was kind enough to
onboard us uh last year uh with the
deacon system and right away as carl's
already showed
we have spent a couple of days in may uh
three or four days in may passing out
these gps tracking devices to our
golfers
at rtj and this is a heat map of the
data so this is indicating where
everybody tees off here's another
forward t
this looks like it's a popular landing
area and of course uh it looks like
everybody's playing to the back of the
screen some people hit it up short this
is probably carl's drive over here right
so uh carl and a few of his buddies and
his drive over here so you can visualize
the actual data using this this again is
carl's example and i like this carl this
is where you took out the higher
handicappers and one of the things you
you know you know drew my attention to
let me see if i can
change the color of this thing
let me make this color
blue so you can see it so carl i think
you said you know you see the spread
uh for these golfers or at least the
majority of them you know right down the
middle on the first hole and then you go
to the next hole
and again you see the
way
bigger spread
on the really good golfers right these
are the less than seven handicapped
here's the here's the
the i would call these people good
golfers right around 15. uh these are
the really good golfers uh less than
seven
and of course you demonstrated the value
of that data um
you know it with the with it with the
native area right right over here so
john welcome to the show i got some cool
pics uh here you are with good old pat
o'brien i didn't know o'brien was a
steeler fan
but you certainly as a missourian are
are a chiefs fan was good to good to see
that and you know i was also good to see
in uh in the usga page how you guys are
promoting this system uh and then so
here are the questions for today john
and i'll bring in on simple things like
this um how do you what are some simple
steps guys can do even if they're not
ready for deacon
what are some simple steps guys can do
to get started
and what i like what the usga has done
is the deacon system makes it easier for
me to talk about it so i like and
talking about it with golfers essential
as well so i wonder if we couldn't start
with that conversation john welcome good
to see you i've been staring at those
slides uh and not you so um well maybe
let's start with the data thing
where's where should guys start with
this
well i i think uh well first off thanks
thanks for the invitation it's great to
be here and uh for the setup um i i do
think
throughout the industry most good golf
course operations they're collecting
some amount of data already
um and it might be as simple as going
out each morning and
and using a moisture meter to kind of
get an idea of where the greens are for
that day and then they communicate that
information to whoever is going to maybe
be mean to water greens or check greens
um they kind of you know establish some
type of
uh you know targeted
uh level that they're going to try to to
water too and get them you know through
the day where they have good turf health
but then also good playability
uh the difference you know where where
you got true i guess data uh geeks
versus the you know just kind of more
art uh focused superintendents is
you know a lot of people take those
measurements or make that that initial
assessment
and then they just make a decision and
go from there they don't they don't ever
record it or if they do record it it's
in some
excel spreadsheet that they never really
sit down and go through and try to to
really understand and interpret what
what those numbers mean or compare year
after year
so
things like deacon
allow you know superintendents just an
easier way to
put that information in their phone
and then not worry about it
in the event they do want to go back and
look at the last 30 days last two years
then they can really understand so it's
it's not like
you know if they want to start doing it
they have to kind of start from from
nothing because most people are doing
some type of assessments whether it's
you know looking in the the
buckets and seeing how many you know
clippings they got and going maybe i
need to you know back off on some
fertility maybe i need to increase my
pgr
uh frequency but
you know it's just not that much harder
to take an actual volume
and then once you take that volume it's
not that much harder just to put it into
your phone and then have it in somewhere
you can easily access so
you know there's a lot of capabilities
with some of these different technology
tools but by and large it's it's meant
to be you know five minutes or less of
your day
and it gives you a real strong
historical record so that's got to be
the key right doing it um
making it so it's easy to put in
and easy to interpret larry stoll did a
podcast with me and scolded us you know
well we want them to be data-driven but
we don't make it easy for them or we
want it to be data-driven and we're not
necessarily giving them actionable data
right that's i think another important
thing is you know what is data and what
is actionable data what is data that
you're going to take action
as a result when you go out and talk to
guys like the spiel you just gave us
it's only five minutes i'm still sure
you hear like well you know
and
i don't know how much longer folks like
that are going to make it if they don't
start doing some data and like many are
doing it but i still feel this through
this res there's this reluctance to
fine-tune
their
practices
based on the data they're just oh it's
there i don't do anything with it yeah i
think you know sometimes with with these
programs or new technologies there's
this
fear that
it's going to be completely automated
and there's no decisions made by the
superintendent and his staff
so i mean at the end of the day
it's just hopefully going to be able to
present it in a a way that you can
really interpret easily and compare
but you have to decide if that's a good
level or not a good level you got to
decide if you want to go faster or
slower
you know if you want to if you want to
water you don't want to water how much
so so
it doesn't necessarily take the control
away from uh these turf managers who you
know are are so good at what they do
uh
more than anything it just kind of helps
to keep create like a you know
historical record so whether they're
trying to train somebody else and show
this is how we
manage our greens this is how we manage
our moisture this is how we manage our
our growth
or
to their you know who they report to
their their general manager their their
board members their owner
um
those folks don't necessarily have you
know the the bandwidth to understand all
the little intricate you know pieces
that go into making good golf greens but
they can easily look at a graph or a
chart and see okay you know trend lines
this is what we've done today or this is
how we compared to last year and so
um you know talking about your your
weather that you were going over this
spring and kind of comparing that to
last year you know you don't have to be
a turf expert or a scientist to
understand that okay it looks like it's
been drier than normal here that's why
i'm good
so
it's kind of taking that same you know
there's a lot of data that goes into
making those those colorful charts and
so like a program like deacon allows you
just to enter in a few data points
and then those charts are already made
you don't have to be an expert in excel
and taking raw data and trying to create
a bunch of macros and then you know if
you have an issue trying to go back and
fix it and where did i put it where did
i save it and then having you know 12
different spreadsheets that don't really
communicate to each other that's right
so listen uh then my old guy question
for today i usually have an old guy
question all the time
uh you know i was originally motivated
to want to be better at turf beyond a
four-year degree when i met jim the late
jim snow so i wanted to get a master's
degree and be a usga agronomist so i've
been paying attention to all the
knuckleheads that have gone before you
right that you've uh replaced that i
love dearly and have done a great job i
mean obviously
the the the usgs has evolved over the
years and now it looks like based on
what you're doing here
that it's a much more focus on
playability what are the kinds of things
we can help superintendents
talk to people about the playability of
the golf course not
mowing heights and
this and that but you know what the
golfer experiences
this looks like it's a first step what
else are you guys thinking about
relative to playability or things you
would like to see us be doing more with
regard to communicating directly about
playability which you know has been
pretty much confined to green speed
yeah maybe there's a little bit more
firmness now but what else are the kinds
of things you talk about with
playability that are critical for you
know to have some data to do that and
talk to the golfers mm-hmm yeah well i
mean green speed you know
for so many years uh just looking at you
know the the putting conditions it's
been pretty much one-dimensional and
it's been you know we've got this this
easily uh measured uh you know uh uh
tool that allows us to kind of go
through and put a number and then
golfers hear it and you hear it on
broadcast and and then you know it's
it's
over the years become well faster is
clearly better so you know 12 is better
than 11 and 11 is better than the 10.
um and i think for a number of years
there that was that was true you know
when you look at when the late 70s when
the the you know kind of modern snip
meter was released and we did a
like a thousand putting green survey
throughout the country you had a lot of
greens that were rolling seven and a
half you know maybe topping out at eight
feet
well now we have teas and collars that
roll that fast and so
um you know they're they're smoother
they're truer
and and so i think you know for a number
of years that was that was a great thing
but
you know just even in the last decade
we've we've really seen where those
excessive speeds have really taken away
from some pretty cool golf courses some
neat architectural features you know
we've uh reduced the number of available
hole locations on greens because we're
we're you know running these uh you know
golden age designs at speeds that were
never even thought of so
um
now you know there's kind of this idea
of well how do we you know
how do we kind of reign that in and try
to find an ideal range and so that's
something that you know i think is a
popular discussion now um using the stem
meter but uh for the last couple years
we at the usga
have been working
on uh some some other ways to measure
putting green performance and our newest
uh tool that we have that we're we're
still going through a uh
like a beta testing with it and really
trying to better understand how greens
vary throughout the year but uh it's
called the gs3 and and basically it's a
smart golf ball that uh measures not
only green speed um so we can we can
correlate that back to our you know
historical reference point of a stent
meter reading
but it allows us to measure the surface
smoothness and trueness so both the
vertical deviation and then the lateral
deviation
um so it puts a in a number to these uh
surfaces
um right now we are
going through kind of a testing phase of
looking at all different types of grass
species all different parts of the
country trying to get some good uh
baseline information but
eventually
this tool will be available for for golf
courses and and um it'll allow us to
kind of change the the discussion from
green speed to maybe you know at what
speed are our greens the smoothest and
true notes or you know they roll true uh
because
at the end of the day when you see your
golf ball wobbling doesn't matter how
fast they are you know you're that's
going to be kind of in your head and
that's going to make you misput so
um that's that's one tool that
incorporates and works closely with
deacon um
and something we're working on as far as
like kind of overall golf experience
outside of the putting greens um last
couple years we've also been doing some
some work with some
like hotel uh restaurant management type
experts looking at from like a
hospitality standpoint when a golfer
steps foot on a golf course you know
from from the minute they park their car
to the minute that they leave you know
that entire
journey mapping journey
and so how they how they you know what
what aspects in course conditions i mean
by and large from you know the initial
research are are a huge you know a
factor in their overall experience but
you know there's a lot more to it as far
as how they're how they're greeted you
know how they you know uh uh the the
condition of you know the cleanliness
the condition of golf carts everything
kind of goes into it that overall
experience
uh but but conditions and things that
superintendents are directly responsible
for are
are you know top of the list excellent
so listen before i got one last question
before i let you go because you didn't
mention firmness
where are you guys with
firmness because
i think getting it firm makes a lot of
these other things really easier to do
are we dialing in firmness i mean i know
you guys developed a true firm and then
there was this other uh device that the
the scout
the other one
and then the pga uses the ball with the
chain
right right so where are you guys at
with firmness and then carl you can ask
a question or two and we can get out of
here where are we
so so we still use the um original true
firm for all our our championship uh
preparation so
uh here at the country club and and and
uh i don't know how many days but it's
coming up here pretty soon uh we will be
you know using that tool along with the
stent meter to kind of you know make
sure we've got the greens um in in a
consistent fashion and kind of where we
want from a championship perspective so
we still use that there's the
um
spectrum uh we partnered with them to
offer a similar unit that they can you
know give a number to a superintendent
that's commercially available like you
said the pga tour uses a a chain and a
heavy ball and then um uh you know a
caliper to measure how big an
indentation is on the surface
um the the gs3 that i referenced earlier
um
also
can can measure firmness so we we put it
in a a weighted uh uh device drop it
similar to the the true firm and and it
it communicates that information via
bluetooth to our phone so yeah okay so
so we can yeah so it incorporates that
as well um firmness is is a very
important topic i think with with
putting greens uh but but throughout the
you know golf course approaches uh
fairways
um so
i think you know having a way to
objectively measure uh firmness and kind
of correlate that to you know your skill
level of golfers and try to find an
ideal range is important and and you
know maybe we can push back on sometimes
of these uh
these i would think a lot of times false
narratives of well the superintendent
just likes to over water or or you know
we're clearly doing something that you
know
versus maybe the discussion needing to
be well you know we could we could
utilize some you know some
drainage in this area we don't have any
you know very good uh soils that they're
slow draining maybe we could you know do
something in that regard so firmness is
still important and i think to the the
highest caliber of player it's something
that's you know
on their radar equally as green speed or
any of these other topics
perfect carl um on that on that topic
john in the last couple years i think
there was this sort of you know
quote-unquote coveted boom a lot of
people coming out to golf courses
spending more money
i've been seeing more projects more
infrastructure projects on golf courses
you talk about the false perception that
superintendents are over watering really
mother nature has over watered us at
least here in new york recently a lot of
the northeast are you seeing more money
spent on on drainage projects uh in your
recent travels
yeah i think last year um throughout the
northeast i mean there was a lot of
areas that were pretty wet throughout
the golfing season and you add more more
play to those areas whether it's uh you
know golfer foot traffic or golf carts i
mean these these weaknesses really show
up especially when you go from 15 000
rounds to 20 to 25 000 rounds so you see
these these weaknesses within your your
overall infrastructure
um so yes i think drainage in in
fairways uh greens um even even some of
the winter injury we're seeing uh uh you
know guys deal with right now
uh you know a lot of it goes back to
drainage and
and so you know having green agreeing
that trains well
in you know the winter early spring is
important for maybe limiting winter
injury but it's equally important you
know during july when you've got a big
tournament and you're trying to get out
there and mow and get people to you know
play golf so
um i think the last
you know since we've had two years of
really good golf activity
uh i think people are are very
comfortable in in trying to address some
of these weaknesses and and that's why
we've seen this huge
you know flurry of activity um from a
lot of projects
thanks for taking the time to join us
john it's what a joy to have you it's
it's it's so great
that's so great thank you for the
opportunity yeah happy glad to have you
carl
yep excited to hear that the usga
working on these data things where we're
awaiting that gs3 device we've been
screwing around with children's toys and
and other machines for a while now so
that's interesting to us thanks everyone
for joining you can find some links
below in the youtube video
to this usga research john was talking
about about uh you know the involving
the hotel people satisfiers
dissatisfiers every part of the golf
experiences is included in there i
highly suggest you check that out uh not
just from a conditioning perspective the
experience as a whole but uh thanks john
again for joining us we'll see you guys
tomorrow with sold out talking soils
excellent bye
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu